all right so so after all the talks okay
can everybody hear me yes all right so
after all the talks yesterday I was
thinking of doing this and joining the
trend I talked about something more
theoretical but Ben said it's okay to
talk about practical stuff so so we're
not gonna do that
yesterday maybe not today okay
so black Hornet set is pretty widely
used for a large-scale optimization
really easy to implement not big memory
requirements you don't need to infinite
ram there's cheap iteration costs and it
can be used in distributed setting it's
been used for almost two decades for
lasso and SVM problems which are kind of
two the canonical optimization problems
in machine learning and so if we can
improve on this method we can probably
affect a lot of applications so this
work is basically a grab bag of
different ways to try and make existing
BCD methods go faster
there's no unifying theme but hopefully
you'll see one of them that's at least
interesting for your problem so my
notation we're minimizing a function f
of X in R to the N we're gonna say that
f is differentiable and n is large for
most of the talk we'll talk a little bit
about non smooth problems near the end
each iteration of BCD you select a block
BK and it's going to be a subset of 1 to
n and then you take an update and we use
this notation u BK to basically grab
columns of the identity matrix that
means this DK is going to be the size of
BK and we just update the coordinates
associated with BK and we choose this DK
usually so it improves on the the
subproblem if I just focus on the
Subspace associated with the blocks I
chose so for example I might just take
the gradient of the blocks that I chose
and take a negative times a step size so
I do like a gradient descent step on
that block so whenever you talk about
coordinate set you always have to
include the slide even though many
people do not
so coordinate set is actually a provably
bad algorithm in general it's actually
slower than gradient descent in terms of
the convergence rate and the iteration
cost in the worst case is actually
basically the same as gradient descent
so if you have okay so so we'll come
back to that but it's actually widely
used in practice so so for certain
problems nothing seems to work better so
maybe not the most effective for fitting
em nests but for a lot of problems and
statistics they really like this
algorithm kourin ascend is also using
graphical models and a bunch of other
settings and it's quite hard to beat in
some of these settings so if you haven't
seen this before this seems kind of
weird that we've got this our than that
lots of people use and has terrible
theoretical properties so we've recently
understood coordinates and a little bit
better and this sort of started with a
work of Nesterov and there's been tons
of papers on this lately who analyzed
randomized coordinate descent so I pick
a random coordinate or a random block of
coordinates and then I do a gradient
descent step on that and one of the
conclusions which isn't spelled out
explicitly but it is implied by this
work is if I can make my quarter descent
iterations n times cheaper than my
gradient descent iterations then I might
be better off doing coordinate descent
it turns out that in these fields where
they use corn to send a lot this was
actually true so we need to talk about
if you're gonna fly corn descent we need
a class of problems where it actually
makes sense to apply corn descent
because otherwise you shouldn't do it
and here's the class of problems that I
like to talk about so we're gonna
minimize a function let's say G of X G
of X can have a separable term it can
have what I call a pairwise separable
term so a set of functions that depend
on pairs of variables and this
composition of a smooth function with
with a matrix a times
X so why is that sort of class special
well if I have the separable functions
updating one of those functions is is n
times faster than updating all of them
so that's nice this one's a bit weird
but if you think about updating one X I
I change n terms in that sum whereas
there's n squared terms in that sum so I
can do it n times faster and then this
one is also a little bit weird but the
key idea here is if you track a X you
can actually do the updates in o of 1
instead of o of n when you have n
variables so when you're talking about
core innocente you're pretty much only
talking about problems that can be put
in this form now this seems like a
really restricted class but it includes
a lot of functions so most of the models
in machine learning fit in this
framework so if we have like an least
squares term and an l1 regular Iser I've
got my separable term and I've got my f
of a X if I have a quadratic function in
the last talk I've got my separable term
and I've got my pairwise separable terms
so there's actually tons of objective
functions that show up in machine
learning that have this structure and
that's one of the reasons it's become so
popular in machine learning
if I let you update blocks of variables
instead of one at a time it opens up
some new problems like group l1
regularization where you have some sort
of group separable versions of the
problems on the last slide if people
know of other problems where you can
apply quarter descent please email me I
always ask this and nobody ever does so
so so coordinates that might just be for
problems that can be written in this way
maybe maybe Ben will come up with
someone at the end of the talk
well many people want more than that but
for this talk we're only going to talk
about those problems okay so our usual
assumption when we analyze corn ascent
is we say we're lb block-wise Lipschitz
continuous so if I change the
coordinates B by some value D we're less
than L times the norm of that D and if
you have a twice differentiable function
it's just saying that if I grab the B by
B sub matrices its eigen values are
bounded above by L there's lots of ways
to pick the blocks and there's lots of
ways to pick the directions so here's a
canonical randomized BCD method which I
think was the one used in the last talk
maybe Ben can verify that
so I partition the coordinates into
blocks so just just 1/2 tau tau plus 1
up to 2 tau and so on then I choose a
block uniformly at random and then I do
my gradient descent step with a step
size of 1 over L for the block is that
the previous talk algorithm well except
for the quadratic case you can do it a
full step okay so here you use a line
search which works much better ok if you
employ this algorithm actually in the
quadratic single core in a case 1 over L
B is the exact step investor yes blocks
yeah yeah that's right
ok so you see this algorithm in a lot of
papers if you implement it and try it
out and you generate your your least
squares problem from like random
Gaussian data it works great if you
apply it to a real problem this actually
often works pretty badly and and we saw
that in the last talk ok so so let's
think about this we can make a block
wise version of the descent lemma so we
can bound how much f of XK plus 1 is
going to be lower than F of XK in terms
of the gradient and how much we move and
this value L if I plug in that step from
the last slide I get this progress bound
which is saying that how much I improve
the objective depends on the norm of the
block and the Lipschitz constant of the
block if I now take the expectation of
that where star
to the block I can get sort of a bound
on how much progress I make with random
sampling but for certain problems you
can do a little bit better than uniform
sampling so I'll show the structures on
the next slide but two things you can do
one is when is Lipschitz sampling we
actually choose the block proportional
to its Lipschitz constant so if the
Lipschitz constant is big we're gonna
sample that block more often because we
expect the gradients to be changing
quite quickly another thing you could do
is called Gauss Southwell where we
choose the block maximizing the norm
here so if you look at this bound if I
make this norm as big as possible then I
can in some sense expect the most
progress if all the Lipschitz constants
are similar now when you first see this
this looks really strange
how can i compute the max of the
gradient n times cheaper than the
gradient okay so let's think of a
problem with a very sparse Hessian ten
non-zeros per column and I have the
gradient from the last iteration when I
update one coordinate I'm only gonna
change ten gradient values so instead of
recomputing the gradient from scratch at
each time what I do is I track the
gradient and if not many values are
changing then I can actually maintain
the max the whole time by just using a
max-heap to keep track of where the max
is at all times
it actually works not just for sparse
problems if you have a dense quadratic
problem as in the last talk it also
works it ends up being the Gauss
Southwell basically has the same cost as
randomized at least in own notation the
the condition you actually need is the
max degree of the Hessian if I view the
Hasina's and as an adjacency matrix it
needs to be similar to the average
degree so so that's great for super
sparse graphs it's great for dense
graphs what you cannot have a star
graphs you can't have one node that's
connected to everybody we don't want
hubs or things like that if you don't
have that there was some work recently
talking about how to approximate the
Gauss southwell with a nearest neighbor
search problem for certain linear models
so that's that's kind of neat now yep
it's a question of why are we using a
step size as opposed to a Newton step
well we'll get there in like three
slides yeah we definitely don't want to
use the gradient step okay so instead of
choosing the block that maximizes the
norm here we really have this lbk in our
bounds so we should use that too so we
call that the Gauss southwell Lipschitz
rule if you incorporate the gradient
norms and the Lipschitz constant
basically has the same runtime is using
Gauss Southwell but it's a bit faster
the intuition here is if I have two
coordinates and they have almost the
exact same gradient I should choose the
one whose gradient is changing more
slowly because if I take a step along
that direction the gradient is going to
sort of stay
big as I go along that direction and so
I can expect to make more progress
another thing to talk about is when
you're in the Bloch case this issue of
fixed blocks versus variable blocks so
for a lot of problems we just partition
the coordinates into a set of blocks of
roughly equal size and then we just pick
one of those blocks well one alternative
you could do is just consider all
possible blocks up to some size tau so
if you consider all possible blocks you
can clearly find one that has a bigger
norm or norm divided by square root of
lb then if you consider these fixed
blocks so if you can afford it you
should use the variable blocks case but
for some problems variable blocks
doesn't make sense so if you do sparse
multi-class logistic regression it ends
up variable blocks is much more
expensive if you have a group separable
problem like group l1 you can't actually
do variable blocks because they don't
respect the non-smooth structure and
something that was kind of weird is that
that rule from the previous slide where
you divide the norm by the Lipschitz
constant ends up being np-hard if you
want to have arbitrary blocks so that's
sort of associated with using fixed
blocks which was a bit surprising to us
so I'm gonna actually show plots in this
stock here's all of our randomized and
cyclic methods on the left is a binary
logistic problem on the right is a
multi-class logistic problem and in
quarter to set papers you see a lot of
this problem but you don't ever see this
problem and coordinates and methods look
pretty bad in that case and this is M
nests but I'm just using multi class
instead of binary or R instead of least
squares so here's all the greedy methods
and they can make quite a bit of
progress so the difference between
adding the delipcious the difference
between being greedy and using random or
cyclic is pretty large and then going to
the the Lipschitz constant helps a bit
and going to variable blocks can also
help quite a bit and we did lots of
plots so so my students have been doing
trying to figure out what really works
these differences get smaller as the
batch size gets bigger so the more
things you're updating at once the less
it matters what rule you use all methods
work better if you do a line search or
if you have the optimal step size
and we also found that if I sorted the
Lipschitz constants and partition based
on that it worked a lot better and this
kind of goes against what the theory
says the theory says we should have
blocks would that have similar Lipschitz
constants but it actually ended up being
work working better if you put all the
big ones into one block and update them
all at once
and I think the reason for that is that
if you can make the gradient of those
close to zero then you're forced to pick
a block that has smaller Lipschitz
constants on many of the iterations at
least half of the iterations so that was
kind of something that the theory hasn't
caught up to yet okay now our ideal rule
is what's called the maximum improvement
I try every possible block of
coordinates and I choose the one that
maximally decreases F now if I have a
quadratic function and I'm using block
sizes of one that rule from the previous
slide that's actually the maximum
improvement rule so if you have a
quadratic function you have to change
one function to save your life you
should choose this GSL rule if you have
box size bigger than one then you don't
want to use that rule there's there's
better rules possible and as was just
asked should we really be doing gradient
steps anyways when we have blocks so
heading towards a Newton step instead of
defined Lipschitz constant based on a
scalar we can use a matrix HB so here
I'm using quadratic norms and I'm
assuming you're one Lipschitz in some
quadratic norm HB not actually a
stronger assumption just changes how we
measure so so one implies the other our
descent lemma now just adds the Hessian
here or the hessian upper bound here and
our update basically ends up being
something like a Newton step instead of
except for instead of the exact hessian
here i have this matrix upper bound on
the hessian okay so if i do that i can
actually consider updates that take into
account that matrix when they're trying
to choose the coordinate so instead of
choosing the one with the biggest norm
or the biggest norm divided by L I can
choose the one that has the biggest norm
measured in its Hessian which I'm
calling Gauss alpha quadratic and this
is nice because if you actually are
quadratic it's choosing the optimal
block
something annoying is I now need these
matrices and this could be very
expensive so the alternative that many
people come up with in this case is to
use a diagonal approximation and we just
make this H a diagonal matrix so once
I've picked the block I still do the the
Newton style step I don't do a
diagonally scaled steepest descent step
but to pick the block to do it quickly I
use the diagonal scaling and a weird
thing is if you make these diagonals
only depend on the particular coordinate
you pick it's actually not np-hard
anymore
so that's kind of a nice thing as we
went to something that seemed more
expensive we made an approximation to it
and that made the np-hardness go away
now this is just as hard as the regular
Gauss South Floral we also played around
with it or if hard thresholding & OMP to
try and solve this those I'll show the
plots but they didn't make a huge
difference so so these are our plots
here's if you use fixed blocks and
here's when you use the variable blocks
so when you're using the variable blocks
and now we're doing the Newton style
update the variable blocks actually help
a lot more than they did when you had
these fixed partitions so that was kind
of interesting when you're doing fixed
blocks there seemed to be no point in
incorporating second order information
into your block you choose it didn't
really help at all and then when you
were doing variable blocks it did seem
to help but the diagonal seemed to
basically have all the work done for you
so there wasn't any reason to use more
expensive matrix updates or stuff like
that so the good news here is that the
sort of better rules are have the same
cost as the classic rule from 1940 so so
that's nice block size we did play with
the block size so I'm just
cherry-picking some results but in our
in our in our paper we have like a 15
plot table that has all sorts of block
sizes and variations and stuff like that
so something that was weird for the
Newton methods is the difference between
these methods actually got larger for
larger batches up to a certain point so
when you were doing Newton updates
having having big blocks and a good rule
actually made a big difference whereas
for the gradient methods you just want
the block small it seemed like big
blocks didn't and
much okay so this was our update using a
matrix now and it's not quite Newton's
method so Newton's method we would have
the instantaneous Hessian and we would
have a step size here and some people
are calling this a Newton block corded
descent but I think that's not the right
name for it because if you consider an
XK where the Hessian is actually much
smaller than its upper bound then the
Newton update can actually make much
more progress than this upper bound
update or if you took a code and for my
Newton's method for all the coordinates
at once and you replaced it by a fixed
Sen you've just thrown super linear
convergence out the window unless you
happen to pick the Hessian at the
minimizer which you probably won't do so
I think even though people are calling
this this Newton method we're calling
this just matrix update to distinguish
those things I'm not calling it quasi
Newton one it doesn't satisfy any
quality if you don't satisfy quasi
Newton equations we're not calling you
quasi yes
do you agree great okay well you've been
thrown around way too much okay so now
the disadvantage of Newton is now we
need to align search or trust region so
if you want it to be really simple you
have to put it in back a bit of extra
effort you have to tune some parameters
and you have to evaluate the function a
few more times so we thought maybe
instead of doing Newton we can do this
cubic regularization of Newton's stuff
introduced by Polly Aachen Nesterov so
instead of using the descent lemma we
actually go to our third order term here
and we assume that the the Hessian is
Lipschitz continuous and then we have
this this bound Tbk on the sort of
continuity of the Hessian so this this
would be nice at least in theory because
I could guarantee the decrease without
having a line search or any extra
function evaluations I could have
negative curvature in my Hessian which
is usually not allowed in line search
methods but that's very nice for non
convex problems and the only problem is
it seems like it's np-hard to actually
compute these TB values and I've been
spamming a lot of tensor people and if
people in the room know
the computational complexity of
computing this for like a logistic
regression problem I would be very happy
to talk but if your block sizes are
small you can actually just compute
these numerically so for block size the
one for logistic regression there's just
analytic formula it's like one over six
times square root of three times like
the three norm of the the largest
example or something like that it's just
just application of quadratic formula
and then for first you know if if the
block sizes are small we can solve
np-hard problems so that's nice just an
example of what the difference is I
don't have the matrix update on this
plot because I've been making my
students do too many experiments but
here's gradient updates this is this is
Newton where we've taken to account the
cost of line search and if you don't
take into account the cost of line
search the Newton and cubic method are
right on top of each other so at least
for this problem the cubic serve gained
you some time so now that we're talking
about Newton methods you should be
thinking super linear convergence and so
you might ask this BC do you have super
linear convergence and the answer is
definitely not so if I give you a two
variable quadratic function and the
off-diagonal is nonzero you can apply
corynn descent but it's not gonna get
super linear convergence even though you
can compute the exact update but there
are some problems where you can actually
get super linear convergence with BCD
and that that's that's the next thing I
want to mention so let's say we have a
smooth F and then a separable non smooth
G so imagine G is is an indicator
function that the X's are positive or
that they're less than some upper bound
or it could be like an l1 regularizer so
we want to get a sparse solution in this
context we usually use what's called the
proximal gradient step so we take a
gradient step with respect to the smooth
part and then we compute what's called
the proximal step with respect to the
non smooth part and many of the issues
are exactly the same in this setting so
you get roughly the same convergence
rate as if you didn't have the non
smooth term you can talk about variable
blocks versus fixed blocks gradient
versus Newton random versus greedy and
so on so so I don't want to talk about
that what I want to mention is some of
the differences so
thing is I had some arguments with my
student because we all thought the Gauss
cell phone rule was a different thing it
turns out there's three different Gauss
cell phone roles in the literature for
this problem only one has the nice
theoretical properties so you want to
look up something called the gsq rule if
you're interested in that and the non
smoothness could actually lead you to a
faster convergence rate so normally we
think of proximal gradient as leading to
a convergence rate that's the same as if
we had a smooth problem but I want to
argue that if we have a non smooth
problem proximal gradient it might
actually converge faster than if we just
had the smooth problem so let's think
about the simplest case possible
minimizing f of X and I want all values
of X to be greater than or equal to zero
so just optimization with non-negative
constraints in this case my proximal
gradient is I take my gradient step and
then I project it so that all the
elements are non-negative so I just set
negative elements to zero and that often
gives us a sparse solution so this is
used a non-negative matrix factorization
non-negative tensive factorization this
has some sort of sparsity in the
solution X star and what I want to
emphasize here is what's called the
manifold identification property is that
if I take all K larger than some K Prime
the sparsity catter pattern of my XK is
going to be the same as the sparsity
pattern of the optional X star so if
you're ultimately interested in what the
final set of non zeros are you don't
have to run the algorithm forever after
some finite number of iterations you
know what the final non zeros are and
this is nice because actually once
you're at the final set of non zeros
you're effectively solving a lower
dimensional problem instead of solving
the problem the original n dimensional
space you're solving the problem in this
lower dimensional space and so your
condition number should be better in the
lower dimensional space
so if you want to prove that that
happens the usual assumption for for
non-negative constraints is that the
gradients at the solution for the values
that should be 0 are strictly positive
they have to be bigger the bigger than 0
so if the gradient is the solution is 0
then you have a problem that you can you
can approach the solution from the
interior but as long as the gradients
bigger than 0 you can actually have this
property so this has been proof for for
BCD methods by by Stephen Wright in a
very nice note for Ferrand and we gave
sort of an alternative proof that's
maybe a little bit shorter but more
importantly we also look at how many
iterations does it take before you find
the final sparsity pattern so there's
many many papers that say you eventually
identify the sparsity pattern but since
we're doing computer science here we
really want like not an asymptotic
result we want a bound on saying if you
run it for this long you find the final
sparsity pattern so if you run projected
gradient and you do condition number
times log of 2 l starting point divided
by Zeta this term here you will have the
final set of non zeros and so so that's
kind of nice so so at that point in time
you know your algorithm is actually
greedy converging faster based on the
final support now this looks a lot like
the convergence rate of gradient descent
and it's very similar except for instead
of epsilon we have this Zeta here and so
if your gradients at the solution are
quite quite positive then you actually
identify the non zero pattern very
quickly and if they're very close to
zero it might take you a long time
before you identify the non zero pattern
we also gave the bound for BCD methods
it's slightly more complicated because
you have to take into how long it takes
but before you pick all the coordinates
that are supposed to be 0 but it's
basically the same idea and we did the
same thing for like L 1 and the general
case so in the general case you have to
have this condition that the gradient is
in the interior of the sub differential
of the non smooth part but basically we
can get bounds on how long if you're
solving L 1 regular least squares how
long it takes before you identify the
final sparsity pattern and I haven't
seen things like that before so that's
nice and it's very simple yeah
so no nuclear norm I don't know group la
so we talked about in the paper what you
need is you would need the the norm of
the group that's supposed to be zero to
be strictly less than the gradient to be
strictly less than lambda yeah
Zeta is like the gap okay so if you have
this manifold property so so this was
the this was known for a long time you
can come up you can say I'll run BCD for
a fixed number of iterations to identify
the final sparsity pattern and then I'll
just run Newton method or quasi Newton
on the non zero variables and get my
super linear convergence that's fine but
we're but even though we know it's
bounded we don't really know how many
iterations to run this for us so so I
prefer hybrid strategies so so one is
you've tried the BCD and the Newton step
on the manifold at each step and take
the best in this was from Stephen
Wright's paper another thing you could
do is you could just do the proximal
Newton version of block cord and ascent
which is not too expensive the blocks
are small and if you have a piecewise
linear GI you can use homo topi methods
to actually compute that pretty quickly
there's also something called to metric
projection methods which is some some
sort of nice compromise between costs
and progress of the iterations if you
use the hybrid method you can actually
get your super linear convergence which
is nice if you use these other two
methods you can get it if you use a
greedy rule and you have sufficiently
large variable blocks so it's actually
possible for BCD methods to get super
linear convergence in some of these
settings because they eventually
identify the final set of non zero
solutions and then they effectively
apply a Newton on those steps which
turns it into a Newton method okay
for quadratic F I should also mention
that when you when you find the final
set of non zero things you're actually
done so if you're solving lasso or
you're solving SVM problems and you use
an approach like this eventually you
find the right set of non zero variables
you solve it and then you have an exact
solve for your SVM or lasso problem so
you don't even have an epsilon anymore
you're just using direct solve which is
nice okay so the last thing I want to
mention is given the lasso in SVM you
can do exact updates are there other
problems where we can do exact updates
and one case is quadratics but there we
need a towel cubed so we can't have our
blocks be too big another case which was
talked about yesterday by leave-in is if
we have sort of sparse quadratics then
we can do this sort of zero fill-in
Challis key factorization and do it
quickly so so this has been sort of used
for a long time and iterative solvers so
if you if you read like demos book or
something like that they'll talk about
red/black ordering where if I have my
structure being a lattice dependency I
update the red nodes and then I update
the black nodes and since they're not
neighbors of each other there's no
dependency I just get a diagonal
quadratic system that's easy to solve
but with the the ideas from like
graphical models and coral graphs and
all that you can instead use things like
trees so if I grabbed a tree structured
sub graph I can exactly compute the
Newton step or do the exact lock update
if it's a quadratic using message
passing algorithms or or which is in in
this case is equivalent to a Achille s
key factorization but with no fill-in so
it's linear time instead of cubic time
okay and that makes a big difference too
so so if you just sort of pick generic
blocks you don't do too well if you
update trees you do quite well and then
the red/black ordering is usually
somewhere between if you have a special
problem where you can use the classic
red-black method
so to wrap up because my voice is not
going to last much longer
sometimes you can really afford to do
greedy BCD methods and in those cases
you probably should so in those cases we
proposed some rules that make them go
slightly faster and they they sort of
can even incorporate second order
information in an efficient way but if
you can afford to do second order
information you probably should cubic
regularization might be a way to avoid a
line search if np-hard problems don't
scare you when they're small you can do
message passing to very officially
updates compute those updates when
you're very sparse and to metric
projection methods are a nice way to
handle non smooth cases and then from
the theory side the most interesting
thing was we gave bounds on the number
of iterations to reach manifold so the
number of iterations you run an l1
solver before it has the final sparsity
pattern which which might be useful in
other settings I can imagine that also
leading to new algorithms where you take
advantage of some property like that
okay I'm gonna end early because as you
may guess my voice is bad I will just
finally mention that this was almost
exclusively work done by my two students
and over over a while but I've sort of
bugged them to rewrite it and make it
right so the the paper will eventually
be up I'm just the bottleneck you know
making it happen yeah thanks for
listening
in this bracelet
form you started the answer is I have no
idea
you can deport any dissent it with exact
steps yeah and what is the cost of the
exact steps
I'm hoping it's n cubed over over end or
something like that yeah so so in that
case it would fit okay but but but in
the beginning you show the form of some
of the files right yeah so so I so you
log the log determined it must have some
special structure that lets you do that
so so maybe I do have to update my list
yeah I mean it's it's I'm still not
completely sold on block core data
center if I still it's not not my
favorite algorithm but we at least got
it working way better than what people
are using right now so and there is also
for as far as conveyance it's also very
paralyzing yeah so I didn't talk about
parallelization at all but in general
the BCD methods are pretty amenable to
parallelization
the only problem is choosing the step
size when you're doing stuff with every
iteration is like you can distribute the
matrix because you have matrices right
there question in the back
my iterations are still nervous stricted
space I agree but I don't know which
space they're in so we didn't actually
do the full analysis we just proved how
long it takes to get to the manifold we
didn't try and prove the total time of
the entire process so that would be
something would be a great something for
someone in this room to do it sort of
proved that the the whole procedure
benefits from this manifold
identification seems to me that you need
to know what's the optimal in order to
verify whether that is true
is there any class of problems in which
you can say even before yeah great
question so so so it seems like I need
to know what the optimal sparsity
pattern is in order to say anything so
all we did is proof balance in the
number of iterations before we know it's
correct so so in that sense I don't need
to know but there is work trying to try
to identify what the optimal sparsity
pattern would be early and that's things
like safe screening rules there's a big
literature on that where you try and
identify it early or try and rule out
variables that can't be part of the
solution yeah just to that point I have
a paper from about ten years ago with
Christine or Evelyn which in the setting
of non-linear programming where it does
reliable identification of the
inequality constraints so it's based on
having it bound to optimality
conjunction with some measure of how
inactive a and so it sort of
asymptotically just just fall PO not
that is a very nice paper and I did not
mention a lot of references because I
made the talk last night but we have 180
references in the paper BCD is a very
well explored space and we tried to be
very thorough in sort of characterizing
all the things that have come before so
so when the paper is up which will
hopefully be soon there there will be a
lot of these these things in there
great question okay so the question is
if I if I make some sort of like
statistical assumptions on the data
maybe I can bounds ADA I would love to
see that III not off the top of my head
I have no idea how to do that but um I'm
not I'm not a statistician but that
would be really neat if you could do
that
there's just hard hard to figure that
out you haven't done any experiments
trying to characterize that I know that
it happens way faster than you expect so
so there there there has to be some sort
of explanation for why it happened so
quickly
yep so you mentioned for some of the
problems that especially when you have a
few blog server and your blokes gets
really large that this grouping by the
smoothness parameter actually helps so
I'm wondering that's actually Israel so
in a very special case when you only
have two blocks their results that say
that you are actually saying your
running time is the minimum of
optimizing collective two subproblems
but the catch is that you would be you
need to solve them after all
now I suspect that this could be
generalized to like any constant number
of blocks but again the catch is whether
you're solving things like what you're
just doing the gradient step or some
others that were if you're really doing
the line surgeon doing like just
minimizing really well over blocks yeah
so so I don't completely follow the
minimum thing maybe we can talk about
that afterwards but um so related to
this is I had a guy come to me and say
he wants to do a postdoc with me and and
when you're from my school I usually say
okay let's work on a project for three
weeks and I gave him a project similar
to that saying like um you know is that
really the optimal rule if I'm gonna do
a sequence of steps and he came back two
weeks later with a whole bunch of math
and saying no it's not optimal they're
better ways to do so I think I will give
him a postdoc
your steps over blocks were really
really good yeah
so so I my thought is you should always
take the best step on the block possible
so the very first experiment I showed we
were doing gradient steps but I wouldn't
advise doing that at all you should do
like the Newton step or something more
fancy you can like especially if the
blocks are small you can always afford
to do something more fancy than the
basic step I want the last question sure
you don't like think about it tell me
over lunch the two things that I use are
l-bfgs and Sag right now all right let's
take mark again
[Applause]